عندما يتعلق الأمر بفقدان الوزن الصحي أو الحفاظ عليه ،
يمكن أن يكون هناك العديد من
المقاييس
لتتبع الرقم على مقياس مؤشر كتلة الجسم الخاص بك
وعدد السعرات الحرارية التي تستهلكها
حتى الرقم الموجود على العلامة داخل
الجينز ولكنك قد تتجاهل
الأرقام التي تحسب حقًا
في
كتبت أخصائية التغذية كارا روزنبلوم في مقال منشور في واشنطن أن
هذه هي الأرقام التي تهتم بها هي
وزملاؤها أخصائيو التغذية
حقًا بحوالي نصف طبقك
بدلاً من حساب السعرات الحرارية ،
استخدم نموذج الطبق البسيط املأ نصف
طبقك بالخضار
وبعض الفاكهة ربع واحد بالبروتين
و  الربع الآخر من الحبوب الكاملة
25 إلى 35 جرامًا ، يمثل هذا النطاق من الأرقام
كمية الألياف التي يجب أن
تتناولها كل يوم لمساعدتك في محاربة
السرطان ، ويقلل من نسبة السكر في الدم ويساعدك على
الشعور
بالشبع لمدة سبع إلى ثماني ساعات ، وهذا هو
مقدار النوم الذي يجب أن تحصل عليه كل ليلة
150 دقيقة  يتم اختبار المقدار الموصى به من
النشاط البدني كل أسبوع
للعثور على مستوى الجلوكوز الصائم لديك ،
أي شيء يزيد عن 100 يعني أنه يمكنك ذلك  كن
مصابًا بمرض السكري
120 فوق 80 ، هذا مستوى ضغط الدم الطبيعي ،
ابق على رأس هذه الأرقام
وصحتك العامة
تأكد من إجراء فحوصات منتظمة من
طبيبك في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم
أنا ريد بينيون